a makeshift shrine at the site of 24
year old Chris caber's killing in a case
that's gripped the British Capital he
died from a single shot to the head by a
police Marksman through a car window at
close range
the rapper and construction worker was
unarmed and weeks away from becoming a
father
police say the car was linked to
Firearms offenses but they weren't given
cabba's name because the car didn't
belong to him the killing sparked A
desperate search for answers from
cabba's family and calls for criminal
charges against the officer who pulled
the trigger that officer has been
suspended while the independent office
for police conduct carries out a
homicide investigation
how can a young man sitting in a car
unarmed be shot in the head by a police
while the independent investigation into
what happened on this London Street
continues the killing of Chris Caba has
reopened questions of police competence
and even allegations of institutional
racism and for others who have lost
their loved ones as a result of police
action kaba's death has reopened Old
Wounds
Marcia Riggs brother Sean a
schizophrenic died after being
restrained in police custody he was
arrested for the theft of a passport
which was actually his own and Angie
Lewis whose 23 year old son Shaney died
when he was held down by 11 police
officers while he was a patient in a
mental health hospital
and Anna sucienta mother of 17 year old
Jack he drowned after being chased into
a river by police
the young men have worn Common Thread
none willing to Crime all were ethnic
minorities all desperately in need of
help my generation the older donor
retired and were exhausted the problem
is they're doing it to our youth and so
we are double traumatized why can't the
government
see this where is their Humanity
was previously the most senior Asian
woman in the Met police before quitting
over racist and sexist abuse she's
demanding urgent police reform what
happens internally is then replicated
externally so you know sexism the
um racism the misogyny that's that's
displayed internally certainly does get
carried out into the community
stereotyping in policing particularly
stop and search particularly when it
comes to young black males is live and
kicking and it's very real the Met
police and the National Police Chiefs
Council declined to speak to us on
camera the Met police issuing this
statement saying we continue to fully
support the independent office for
police conduct investigation as they
work to establish the facts and try to
answer the many questions Mr kaba's
family and others have around his tragic
death
it could be nine months for
investigators to come back with their
findings in that time distrust in the
police amongst the city's black
communities deepens while kaba's family
who viewed the police body cam footage
of the killing continue to demand
Justice
Neve Parker Al Jazeera London